luke here with the outdoor boys youtube
channel i've got a pretty amazing video
for you today i'm deep here in the
alaskan mountains searching for the
wreckage of a bomber plane from the
1950s it's going to be climbing over
massive peaks sleeping in below freezing
conditions and we're also going to
explore an abandoned gold mine i hope
you enjoy the ride because it's going to
be awesome
[Music]
do not be eaten by a bear all right well
yeah see you dad
it is sure gorgeous today but it's cold
it's 46 degrees i think it's gonna get
well below freezing tonight
starting to get the blood going i think
i can take my jacket off that sun keeps
popping out and at this elevation it's
intense how to go and put some sunscreen
on it's probably one of these days when
we get sunburned in hypothermia
see those massive mountains right there
got to get over the top of them
good thing i'm wearing my big boy pants
gotta go up that thing
oh we're doing stairmaster alaska
edition
it gets a little tricky following the
trail in the rocks here but i know i
have to follow the creek and the creek
goes that way
this rock slide has buried the river
man that is some clear water
yeah
all right that's the next set of
mountains i gotta get over
[Applause]
check it out this is one of the springs
that feeds the river if you have to
drink untreated water this is where you
do it
see right there in the rock that's a
parky squirrel chirping at me
when i was a teenager me and my brother
shot and ate a couple of those parky
squirrels
they were not good
all right that's the next set of
mountains i gotta go over
that has got to be the prettiest color
water i've ever seen
done about three and a quarter miles i
think i'll take a little snack break
me and my boys caught some sockeye
salmon a few days ago and i smoked it up
last night
oh it smells so good
love it
all right that's the next set of
mountains i need to go over
[Applause]
now i'm not sure what our water
situation is going to be on the other
side of those mountains so i'm going to
bust out my water filter and top off all
my water bottles
so i've got a three liter water bladder
and a water filter that screws into the
end of it
i just hold up the bladder and gravity
pulls it through the filter we'll fill
up that bottle in about 60 seconds
wow that's really pretty but also very
daunting because i've got to get over
that ridge right there and not only is
it huge it's got fresh snow up there
see that right there on the tip of that
rock right there a little mouse called a
pika the pikas and the parky squirrels
will sit up on the rocks and make a
little alarm sound when you come by to
let everybody know you're in the
neighborhood
oh this is a nasty terrain
that's the next ridge i need to get over
you hear that it sounds like a little
girl screaming
i think it's an animal though that is
eerie
oh it gives me the creeps though
now we go up that
i think we found a little marmot den
here
it's a marmot poo
marmot just kind of a big fluffy rodent
that lives up here in the alpine areas i
might take a little snack break oh i eat
some dried figs
i love dried figs
oh i finally figured out what that
screaming sound was
there was a bird of prey sitting up on
this cliff over here
tell you what i might be crazy
but that ridge is starting to look
doable
all right that's enough dilly dallying
when you're at the base of the mountain
you have to go and plan out your route
up
because once you're here
you can't see well enough to do it
and if you go up the wrong shoot you
could end up
dead ending at a cliff or something
oh my god check it out right there in
that ice field that's a crashed air
force bomber
that's where we're headed it's cold up
here there's remnants of the snow storm
they had last night
all right i'm gonna grab this stone here
so if i slip i can try to stop myself i
really should have brought crampons or
an ice axe
oh
see right here this is ice
i step on this
all the way down to the bottom
i don't want any part of that
if i stay in this white soft stuff i got
pretty good traction
that dark stuff is death traps
i can hear water under the ice
gotta be careful i don't step into a
stream see water coming out right here
this is nasty business all this stuff
right here is so steep and so icy
so i'm going to try to get into this
rock field so i can have something to
hold on to and up there on that steeper
part i can tell that soft snow so i'm
gonna go across on the rocks
stay high and then come down on the snow
decided to come over here because the
snow looked a little softer
but there's a very slick sheet of ice
underneath about one inch of soft snow
this is just crazy sauce i don't have
any business being up here i mean look
at this
that is so slick i am going to head back
to safe snow
and then reevaluate if i get some
momentum i am just not going to stop
i don't have the equipment for this
well i just wasted about 45 minutes on
that failed approach
i think my best bet is to go over here
see if i can find a safe way down and
then to trek across the valley on the
flatter spot
this is so icy
oh i don't want to jinx myself but i
think
i might have found a spot down
looks like there's this little crack in
the snow that goes all the way across
might be able to use that to get across
let's see it's a lot less steep here i
feel like if i slip i've got a much
better chance of stopping myself too
but you can see right up there was where
i was trying to get across that ice
sheet it looks even sketchier from down
here
what is that
this is their radio
look at this this must be the cockpit
here
so this plane is a tb29 super fortress
it's the training version of the b-29
super fortress which is the same type of
plane that dropped the two atomic bombs
on japan
this crash happened in 1957. the plane
had ted crew members and was coming back
from a training mission and got off
course and lost in some bad weather and
struck this mountain one of the four
survivors was able to get his wounded
comrades wrapped up in parachutes and
things and keep them warm until help
could arrive can you imagine
you and three of your wounded buddies on
this ice field waiting for help
gosh
there's a piece of a bag
the main part of the fuselage is down
here
it's a parachute right here me and my
boys actually did a video where we used
a parachute just like this to build a
survival shelter it's almost exactly the
same one
this is one of the four engines
i think this is an old life raft
there's engine number three
oh
this monument honors those that stand
and those who have fallen in the service
of our country may you take with you
from this place a renewed respect for
all those that protect our freedom
a bit of a parachute or something
us air force
tires have been here for 70 years they
look pretty good there's the other
wheels down there my guess is that
there's a lot more of this wreckage
hidden under the ice and strewn all over
this valley
it's been pretty sobering but pretty
cool to see this wreckage i'm glad i
made it here and put in the effort but
it was quite the effort i've been hiking
for seven and a half hours and it's a
lot later than i thought it was gonna be
originally i was gonna hike over this
mountain
and go down a valley over there and camp
over there but that's not going to
happen tonight so i've got to make some
other plans and i got to make them quick
i've got to make some serious tracks i
don't want to be in this valley when
that sun disappears behind that peak
it's going to get cold and even more icy
i'll tell you what guys i was an
absolute fool to do this without
crampons and an ice axe
i'm gonna be really happy
once i get off this ice sheet
feels good to be on rock again
well i made it down the ice field
without killing myself and i'm really
happy to not be going over that ridge
again
never been this way before so it'll be a
bit of an adventure
whoa
that's a nasty little crevasse
and you see that pink snow right there
that's old snow
that's bacteria growing in the snow it
makes it pink
check it out there's another crevasse
here that's a one-way trip if you go
down one of those suckers
there we go that's the way i'm headed
it's downhill but i'm gonna be taking
the long way home
[Applause]
i'm back in the sunlight feels good
hey look vegetation i remember that
we're getting close to one of the
mountain huts
hey this is the bomber hut this is one
of the kind of public use little huts
that anybody's hiking through the
mountains can kind of use to get out of
the
weather
that's pretty cool you got a little
stove and everything just bring your own
fuel
uh yeah you can oh here we go this is
what i need
that's the bomber wreckage right there
let's see and that's the bomber hut
that's snowbird right there
yeah yeah we walked through some snow
there's a sleeping area up there yeah
well that's cool
you guys have fun i'm gonna head off
well you have a lovely lovely trip take
care
well apparently anybody who wants to can
go sleep in those huts you don't need
reservations or anything it's just a
free service for anybody in the
mountains but
i got some miles to cover it's only 10
o'clock
yep i've been hiking for 10 hours
look how clear that lake is
way up on the hillside you can see the
wreckage of the bomber and the ice field
i crossed
oh feels like it was only a few minutes
ago but that's got to be like two and a
half thousand feet of elevation dip i'll
tell you what i am glad to be done with
that ice field
that was not fun
it's pretty here all the dogwoods in
bloom this little flower is called
dogwood there's bunches of it all over
the place
man i want to do another mile before i
get to bed but it's getting so late
there really isn't any trail right now
i'm just following this valley floor and
the trick to this is to stay high on the
mountainside it's better to deal with
the boulders than to deal with the
marshy low ends and the willows plus
when you're on the side of the hill you
got a better chance of spotting the
trail it's really easy to find the trail
if you're too high
it's really hard to find the trail if
you're too low
oh
look at that that looks like bear poo to
me your best chances of seeing a bear
are late at night early in the morning
so i really i keep my head on a swivel
what do you think
that's pretty gorgeous huh
the black ones are crowberries the blue
ones and blueberries
well guys i'm getting ready to make camp
for the night and i need to refill my
water bottle
it's almost midnight it's getting dark
i've got to find a place to camp and
i've got to find a place to camp where i
won't get eaten by a bear
ah
this'll do
look at how spongy and nice this is look
how flat it is
yeah
i don't think any bears are getting up
here
what do you think guys
i think i just found the perfect
campsite
ah
[Music]
my feet are wet and cold and now that
i'm not moving my whole body is getting
cold real
quick there's a bit of a luxury item i
brought along on this trip
down booties
it's supposed to get down below freezing
tonight this is basically winter camping
they're so warm oh my feet are already
toasty and feeling better all right
we're gonna have some warm herbal tea
with our dinner
kung pao grilled chicken we're gonna
give that a try
i think i'm gonna start calling this my
bear fortress it's impervious to bears
and no bears are getting up here i think
i'm not gonna get eaten by a bear
tonight
got a thermos of boiling water we're
gonna put that in my sleeping bag get
things warmed up it's gonna be cold
tonight
it's 1207 guys and we're just losing our
last little bit
of light that's alaska for you
i'm gonna eat some food
drink my tea i'm getting in that bag
all right time to brush my teeth
i'll see you guys
in the morning
five hours later
ah good morning
it is so toasty in this sleeping bag
and it is so cold outside even having my
face out of the bag this much is really
impossible
my bear proof camping spot seems to have
worked
i'm here
you can see the sun just starting to hit
the tops of the mountains nice when that
sun gets down here
ah dig deep all right
this little sleeping bag shell is
perfect for what i used it for you know
protects you from the wind and bugs and
dew and light drizzle
but that's about it i mean if it rained
really hard this would soak through just
like a rain fly and creates a lot of
condensation inside so my bag is kind of
damp on the outside i'm gonna have to
dry it out but if you're in the
situation i was last night just didn't
have time to build a proper shelter
then it's perfect all right the worst
thing about getting dressed in the
morning is putting on cold pants so i'm
gonna wrap my pants around my hot water
bottle
warm it up before i put them on
i had warm dry socks on for about five
minutes and it was glorious while it
lasted
ah still warm
that's nice
all right guys 6am i've got camp broken
down but we got a long ways to go
just need to figure out where the trail
is need to get down for my bear proof
fortress
i gotta see somebody mush these plants
well it's not a trail but at least
somebody came this way there's a little
bit more of a trail
yeah
ah there's my fortress
that was a fun campsite
a little bit of frost on the plants
definitely got below freezing
horrible part about hiking early in the
morning
the frost and dew gets you soaked
look at this
having been going for 15 minutes
already wet
looks like we're going over that
starting to get the old furnace going i
need to take some layers off that's
better
look sunlight
it's almost reached me i think it's time
to stop for breakfast
the sun's back
oh that feels good
ah the pikas are out in force
they're all barking at me well that
right there is the next mountain to
climb
oh
made it up the ridge
now i've got to tackle that thing
oh
a whole bunch of quartz down here this
is what the old gold miners used to look
for you'd find granite and that would
lead you to quartz and the quartz would
lead you to gold a lot of gold mines in
these hills back in the days
[Applause]
that's ice on that lake
it's the end of july and there's ice on
that lake
i think those might be like a mink or
something
check it out there's a tarmigan right
there in that rock
she's trying to get me to chase her up
the hill away from her babies but i'm
not here to cause any problems so
though if this was hunting season it'd
be a different story because those
things are tasty
oh i took a massive wrong turn and went
up into that valley
i need to go up into that saddle instead
you people at home might not believe
this
but my legs are sore
these stacked rocks are the first sign
of a trail i've seen in over an hour i
noticed that whenever i get over 5000
feet
i really start to pant more you can
really notice that the air is a bit
thinner
now we got to climb that hey i can see
my camping spot from here
yeah there it is
oh that seems like so long ago
check it out here's some edible liking
see this stuff
you boil it
and it gets all soft and mushy tastes
kind of like boiled mushrooms but not as
nice whole bunch of it
all on these rocks
there's a little survival hut right up
there on that ridge
this is called the snowbird hut look at
this view here
this is pretty pretty nice
you see here they got
some bunk beds in here
and a little bit of a loft
a little kerosene heater
some stoves
pretty well stocked
well we started here we went up up up
here that's the wreckage
that's the first hut
that's where we slept
and then we're here and we got to get
across this big glacier
and down in here
there's the mailbox i've got to go down
to that glacier then i'm going to turn
left and go up over this mountain over
here and it should be downhill for the
rest of the trip i'm looking forward to
that all right guys we're on the glacier
luckily it's not too steep and the ice
is pretty rotten so it's not slick
just got to get over
that mountain
this glacier feeds that lake down there
which feeds the stream which feeds the
river i've been walking along most of
the creeks and rivers around here are
fed by snow packs and glaciers
so here in alaska when the weather's hot
you tend to have flooding because of all
the extra ice belt
[Applause]
we made it across the glacier
now i need to climb up that thing
look footprints
maybe i'm heading the right direction
all right guys
we're a little over five and a half
thousand feet
and i'm looking downhill
oh gotta stop and filter some more water
ah
whenever you're hiking with wet feet
it's really easy to get blisters so as
soon as you start to feel that skin
getting raw
throw some moleskin or some band-aids on
it you deal with it before it turns into
a blister your feet last pretty long
time if you wait till after it becomes a
blister you're kind of hosed
you can feel it it's just like tender
right there and there
all right time to keep going
don't let the sunshine and t-shirt fool
you guys
it's cold out here
and the minute you stop moving you feel
it
oh look at this trail yeah i like this
this is nice
look there's another rock armageddon
right there
see how she won't hide or fly she's just
luring me away from her babies
which are probably up there somewhere
[Music]
ah
we got the ruins of an old gold mine you
can see all the timber and steel looks
like a rock slide took it out see right
there that little shadow that's the
entrance to the gold mine all that
timber and steel used to be at the
entrance and a rock slide took it out
and pulled it down the mountain you can
see the tailings pile from all the ore
they dug out right there there used to
be some really big gold mines in these
mountains up until the end of world war
ii price of gold fell and everything
shut down
probably old office building and wash
houses look at those concrete footings
right there and that looks like the drum
they would use to pulverize the ore and
extract the gold
that's coal probably what they used to
heat the place looks like there used to
be another mine entrance over there
check out there's this old mine shaft
here and it's full of water
that's pretty cool
oh i think i figured out how they got
all that equipment up this mountain
these steel cables going down off the
mountain
there's the mine ruins up there you can
see the steel cables run all the way
down here
this little shack
and they continue on down to the valley
floor this wasn't some old guy with a
pickaxe this was a major gold mining
operation
oh you got to work on my feet a little
bit more ah that's better
all right back at it
finally made it back to the trail where
we started
all right guys i'm back where i started
and it took almost exactly 24 hours
my gps says i walk 19 and a half miles
and i estimate that about five of those
miles were with no trail at all there
was a ton of elevation gain and loss on
this trip in the last two and a half
hours i came down 3000 feet but if you
total up all the elevation gain for the
entire trip i believe it's about seven
thousand feet so i came up seven
thousand feet and down seven thousand
feet in 19 and a half miles in 24 hours
my feet are killing me i'm gonna lay
down oh
oh hey guys
when i put the curry on top of it it
looks kind of too good to be here
nice becca
i hope you guys have enjoyed this video
because i sure have if you want to see
more videos like this make sure to click
subscribe to the outdoor boys youtube
channel we put out new videos every
saturday morning all right guys i'll see
you then if you like this video don't
forget to check out the outdoor boys
youtube channel where we have hundreds
of videos just like this and don't
forget to click subscribe so you can see
other great videos every saturday
morning and hit that bell button you'll
get notifications thanks for watching
[Music]